[Musik]
es ist der nackte Judenhass der sich in
diesen Tagen auf deutschen Straßen zeigt
in Berlin zieht eine Demo an einer
Starbucks Filiale vorbei Kunden werden
beschimpft und bespuckt auch weil das
Unternehmen von einem Juden gegründet
wurde für viele in Deutschland lebende
Juden hat mit dem 7 Oktober ein Albtraum
begonnen sie haben Angst es ist ein sehr
sehr komisches Gefühl durch die Straßen
zu gehen und nicht zu wissen ob man
etwas persönlich erlebt ob man Zeuge von
etwas wird und um es mal auf ein Satz zu
bringen man fühlt sich eigentlich wie
eine Zielscheibe seit Wochen werden
antisemitische Parolen gebrüllt
Davidsterne an Haustüren geschmiert
sogar molotovccktails auf Synagogen
geworfen wie sehr jüdisches Leben
angegriffen wird merken Sie bei ofek
einer Beratungsstelle die bei
antisemitischer Gewalt hilft in den
letzten vier Wochen hatten sie so viele
Anfragen wie sonst in einem Jahr das ist
keine Erkenntnis
viele Menschen machen sich Gedanken über
ihre Sicherheit über die Sicherheit
ihrer Kinder jüdische Eltern fragen sich
ob ihre Kinder an jüdischen Einrichtung
noch sicher sind und fragen sich aber
auch gleichzeitig ob ihre Kinder an
nichtjüdischen Einrichtung in sicheren
Räumen sind der Antisemitismus tobt sich
nicht nur auf den Straßen aus in den
sozialen Netzwerken erreicht er viele
junge Leute
elhaft Wall ihr ihr
hat euch Hitler zu wenig oder
was ihr schm allergrößten abschauen mit
ihr dreckslocken und volollgewichsten
wärten ihr miskins ihr seid mindestens
genauso wie die nesdp und ad
Hitler euch Terroristen kann man nur
hassen ich hoffe dass dieser Judenhass
immer größer
wird jetzt zeigt sich der islamistisch
und arabischstämmige Antisemitismus der
sich auf Israel be bezieht ganz deutlich
wird sekundiert von Antisemitismus der
Linken wir sehen also Milieus die
normalerweise nie etwas miteinander zu
tun haben Seite an Seite marschieren
tatsächlich fungiert der Antisemitismus
als ideologisches Bindemittel er kommt
nicht nur wie gerade sichtbar von
Muslimen sondern auch von Christen er
kommt von links und er kommt von rechts
und er reicht bis in die bürgerliche
Mitte hinein wie Studien
belegen der Aussage bei der Politik die
Israel macht kann ich gut verstehen dass
man etwas gegen Juden hat Stimmen 15% zu
weitere
24% teils teils als PU die Ukraine
überfiel versammelten sich 100.000
Menschen am Brandenburger Tor als die
Hammers ihren Terror nach Israel trug
waren es gerade mal 10 000 auch diese
mangelnde Empathie führt dazu dass Juden
Angst haben ihren Glauben öffentlich zu
machen ich bin der Meinung man sollte
dann tatsächlich lieber eine baseecap
über eine kipppa ziehen und dann ist
eben die Frage ob man im öffentlichen
Raum ein Davidstern zeigen soll es ist
schade dass man es nicht offensichtlich
nicht kann aber
man muss eben auch wirklich selber drauf
achten sich nicht zu gefährden das kommt
fast einem Eingeständnis gleich dass
Antisemiten ihr Ziel erreicht haben
dabei geht es nicht nur um das jüdische
Leben in Deutschland Antisemitismus
bedroht nicht nur die jüdische
Gemeinschaft sondern wirklich uns alle
und der Umgang einer Gesellschaft mit
Antisemitismus sagt sehr viel über den
Zustand dieser Gesellschaft und den
Zustand der Demokratie kann man in einer
solchen Situation guten Gewissens Juden
empfehlen in Deutschland zu bleiben da
würde ich jetzt mit der Gegenfrage
Antworten haben Sie eine gute Lösung
wohin Juden oder Jüdin gehen sollen oder
könnten ohne
Sorge doch es sind einige die
Deutschland verlassen wollen ist es für
mich sozusagen ehrlich gesagt nur noch
eine Frage der Zeit ähm bis ich bis ich
Deutschland
verlasse auch wenn weite Teile der
Politik heute an ihrer Seite stehen 90
Jahre nach der Machtergreifung der Nazis
fühlen sich Juden in Deutschland erneut
nicht mehr sicher